the most
beloved of tiny organisms is probably
the tardigrade bumbly cute
chubby and six-legged they look like
macro animals
hence their common names moss piglet and
water bear
and look we love them too
we love them and we will talk about them
on this channel a great deal
but we also have a favorite species that
you
likely have never heard of larger than a
tardigrade though only a single cell
and the fact that you've probably never
heard of stenter
is sad because they are beautiful
magnificent
and powerful organisms so
center
it's a genus of single-celled eukaryote
there are 19
known species but they're probably more
than that some of them
can build mucus houses that they can
hang out in and hide inside of
some carry algae inside of them that
produce food for them
and all of them are astoundingly large
for a single celled organism
some can be as much as four millimeters
long big enough to be seen without a
microscope the biggest
tardigrades which have thousands of
cells
are 1.5 millimeters long one thing
every stenter has in common is the
holdfast organelle
which lets them anchor to a single
location
now they can swim but in an undisturbed
culture
only a few stenters will be swimming
freely
stenters are actually more dense than
water which means that they sink
so that holdfast organelle lets them
save energy once they find a location
that has plenty of food and oxygen
but just because they're anchored that
doesn't mean they can't move
most stenters are also capable of
stretching
a huge amount when attached and feeding
a center body can reach
five to ten times their original length
and that's when it starts to resemble a
trumpet
which is where it gets one of its common
names the trumpet and a molecule
the biggest of all the stenters and one
of the largest
single-celled organisms that exists is
stenter coruleus
they can be the length of a rice grain
there are insects in your backyard that
are smaller than these
massive but common unicellular organisms
they're in freshwater habitats all
around the world
and we here at journey to the
microcosmos have a pond where we find
them
all the time surprisingly they thrive
even when it's freezing cold
we have a stenter culture set from
stinter corulius collected
under 20 centimeters of ice possibly the
lack of predators during the winter
keeps their numbers extra high stenter
corullius
is a part of a group called the ciliates
as is true of all ciliates
stentochrolius have
hair-like structures called cilia the
beating of the cilia propels these cells
in the water when they want to move
around
and it also brings food particles micro
animals and
single-celled organisms in to the cell
mouth
where they are taken inside the cell to
be digested
just like this multicellular rotifer
which is
swallowed by the giant stenter coruleus
and waiting
to be digested we recorded this struggle
for a long time and
even witnessed the rotifer rupturing the
stenter's cell membrane
multiple times each time the stenter
repaired itself and the rotifer never
managed to escape
after 25 minutes the rotifer ceased its
struggle
just a reminder rotifers have a simple
brain
and a simple nervous system they can
feel
i'm not sure about pain but they can
certainly feel stimuli
[Music]
the striking blue color makes stenter
corulius one of the most
beautiful species of the genus stenter
however stinder corulius are not just
big and blue
they also have many abilities you would
not expect to find in a unicellular
organism
including regeneration light avoidance
food selection and reaction to
mechanical stimuli
stinter cruelius is most famous for its
regenerative abilities
if a stentogreulius cell is cut in half
each half
will regenerate into a normal looking
cell at
half the size of the uncut cell after
healing
and reconstructing the missing parts of
the cell these
half-sized cells will grow to the normal
cell size given time and resources
even if the cell is cut into a hundred
pieces
each fragment can eventually become a
normal looking
cell though for successful regeneration
to occur
we need two things the cut piece must
contain at least
part of the macro nucleus and a piece
of the cell membrane the macronucleus of
stender corullius
is visible even under low magnification
it has the look
of a beaded necklace and it extends
along the whole
cell this macro nucleus is highly
polyploid which means that even a
fraction of the macronucleus will
contain
thousands of copies of the entire genome
of stender corullus
even a tiny fragment less than one one
hundredth the size of the stentor
corulus
can reconstitute itself in this way if
both the cell membrane and the
macronucleus are present
portions of stenter lacking either
macronucleus or cell membrane
only survive for a short time and the
whole regeneration process
takes only around 48 hours and you don't
have to take our word for this
sometimes when preparing slides we
accidentally
cut these massive cells and the pieces
of center corulius
are left alive in the slide within a day
they are almost fully regenerated and
after two days
we can't even tell which is the fragment
and which are the unharmed
cells stenticurus can be
cannibalistic as well however no one has
ever managed to record
the initial swallowing this is likely
because
the light of the microscope disturbs the
cells
here we see a stenter making a go of
that
but luckily for the little one it's a
bit too big of a bite
as for that blue color we know why but
we don't know like
why they contain a blue pigment
stenterin
but we don't know what purpose this
beautifully colored chemical
serves we have guesses it's possible
stentarina helps stenter corulius
sense light somehow but there's also
evidence that when a predatory
single-celled organism touches
a stentor coruleus it ejects the pigment
like
squid ink in some cases scientists have
observed the predatory organism pulling
away
unfortunately though we have attempted
to record this process for ourselves
after many hours of attempts
it still hasn't happened while recording
[Music]
but remember this isn't the only species
of stenter
here we have stenter polymorphous this
species is mostly filled with
endosymbiotic algae these algae
live inside of the stenter polymorphis
and produce
sugar via photosynthesis and give some
of the extra sugar to stenter
in exchange stenter provides protection
for the algae
look how small those algae are if you
are
surrounded by thousands of different
species of algae eaters
hiding in one of the biggest things
around would certainly protect you from
getting eaten
look how big they are each dot is a
stenter polymorphous cell
these cells came from an aquatic snail
it had
so many stenter cells on its shell it
was visibly green
now we've been talking about these
beautiful and peculiar organisms for a
long time now
and there is of course still more to
share we'll be working hard to keep our
stenter cultures alive and healthy
and we haven't even talked about the
peculiar way that ciliate's genetic code
works and how stenter
is the only ciliate that uses the same
system for encoding
genes into proteins that you and i do
we'll have to leave that
for a future video for now
enjoy these big blue beauties and hey
thanks for coming on this journey with
us
[Music]
[Music]
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james
follow jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us
that my friends is what the subscribe
button is for
[Music]
you